hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast battle the heat in your
lab facing distorted results caused by
temperature fluctuations presented by
dr. Gary - voodoo giris a senior
automation scientist at Omega
corporation and dr. Catherine Fletcher a
marketing application specialist
detection at t-- can Austria I'm Suzy
Valdez of lab routes can all be your
moderator for today's events we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by pecan and this webinar
participants will discover the benefits
of active temperature control supported
by experimental data from cell based bio
luminescent and biofluorescent assays
assessing cell viability metabolism
death and signaling you will learn how
to design assay and signal measurements
to generate reliable and reproducible
data and avoid false positives before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the Q&A
button located at the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appear on
the screen well as far as many questions
as we have time for at the end of this
presentation also please notice that you
are viewing this presentation in a slide
window to enlarge that window just click
on a screen icon located at the lower
right if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use that Q&A
button and let us know you're having a
problem
this presentation is educational and
that offers continuing education credits
click on that button at the bottom left
corner and follow the process for
obtaining your credits I'd now like to
introduce our two fabulous presenters
first dr. Gary - bitte giris dr. Betty
Girish is a senior automation scientist
at Pro mega corporation in Madison here
Cetus PhD in biochemistry at the
Institute of biochemistry
lavinia Academy of Science Vilnius
lavinia dr. petit giris has extensive
multidisciplinary research and
development experience in systems
automation screening and bio development
biochemistry biophysics spec foster C
and electrical chemistry and our second
presenter is dr. Catherine Fletcher dr.
dr. Fletcher is an application scientist
at t can Austria
she studied molecular biology at the
University of Salzburg focusing on cell
biology and immunology research I'd now
like to welcome both presenters welcome
we'll start with dr. Rita Gris thank you
and hello and thank you for joining us
today one of my passado mega is to
evaluate and validate newly developed
Pro mega asses by screening them against
my small compound libraries after
processing multiple screening data sets
I was quite puzzled by the jigsaw
pattern or periodicity of a data I
observed in all of my screens the graph
on the Left data of 16 plates shows each
for each blade displayed and obvious
gradual signal increase through the each
of 80 data points welcome back to this
graph a bit later of course much more
desirable and expected data distribution
would be on the right graph this
observation inspired me to investigate
this phenomenon and to find the
solutions to avoid it we know that all
chemical reactions are affected by the
temperature
this has fact is quite significant
reaction rate acceleration of two to
threefold it's observed with temperature
increase 410 degrees of Celsius as
described by Iranian equation all
instrument generate heat which affects
the hammer Corrections monitored inside
of those instruments the Tekin people
module is capable of maintaining stable
temperatures from 18 to 42 degrees
Celsius which mitigates this issue today
I will present benefits of multimode
Reader equipped equal and active cooling
module vs readers which are not actively
cooled this investigation and employed
multiple Perham bioluminescence and
biofluorescence
reactions multiplayer multi-plate
multi-well plate real time inside the
reader depends on the couple of factors
number of per wells per plate and also
signal acquisition time correct well
this year on the graph very time of her
high density plates is quite significant
the plate residence time inside the
reader is sufficient to heat up the
plate from 2 to 10 degrees Celsius
depending on the reader all the
measurements I presented a were whereas
assembled in v3 84 wall plates the
acquisition time of 300 milliseconds per
world based on these settings the read
time for one plate was just under
preeminence as this were set up in low
volume created for wall plates total
reaction volumes were 80 micro liters to
investigate for action volume
temperature increase inside the reader
and this Tagaytay situations where
entire plate was filled with the same
reagents while in the other plates was
plate was split to be
one of the reaction regions components
are shown in the picture all data points
obtained from wells filled with the same
reagents were averaged and this average
data value provided one data point for
the acid signal kinetics observation
graphed two separate plates were filled
the same regions and monitored
simultaneously in two separate readers
one web plate was placed in the sequel
spark reader and the other plate in not
actively cooled reader for each plate
read reads were taken every five minutes
and the signal across the plate were
averaged to generate one data point to
read in this graph we can see how
overall reaction signals changes over
time in the reader you will see these
types of a graphs through a presentation
whenever left is the raw signal data
graph and on variety is normalized by
the maximum signal graph now let's start
the example of biome less interaction
signal variations
this is bioluminescence succinate glow
as he for which temperature has one of
the largest effective interaction signal
data points indicated by the filled
circles were obtained on the not cooled
reader and data points indicated by the
open circles were obtained on the chip
all spark reader as you see on vertical
reader signal increases continuously for
the first 20 minutes and when it starts
decreasing contrast with the vet Deacon
who reader were signal measurements
immediately starts gradually decreasing
the signal strength for the first
measurements is quite similar between
both in
Freeman's on the left graph you see it's
around 150 and probably like 30,000
counts measurements were obtained at two
substrate concentrations while one man
magnitude of signal for the two
substrate concentrations different
significantly the normalized graph shows
that succinate glow as your rate is
concentration independent there section
eight consumption rate it's equal at
both succeeded concentrations one and
five micro moles light brown and dark
brown curves what that affects the
reaction rate it's not the substrate
concentration but the temperature after
initial increase in the reaction rate
the reaction signal in may not code
reader clearly decreases at a faster
rate than those in the activity code
reader red graph biofluorescence
reactions also are affected by the
temperature one of a pro Megas cell
viability as is april live glow which
evaluates cell viability by a
fluorescence signal a polite glow as his
cell permobil glycine alanine AF
coumarine substrate enters vessel where
it is active cleaved by the live cells
protease activity to produce the
fluorophore FC coumarine or FC
fluorophore oxidation for this
fluorophores for 15 nanometers and
emission maximum is 500 nanometers
production area of AFC compound in
healthy cells is reflected in the graph
on variety and measured on the not
called reader the reaction of volumes
warms up and per action rate increases
producing more FC fluorophore green and
yellow lines
operate
and room temperature in vehicles Park FC
water for accumulation it's slower and
signal increases more slowly blue line
interactions with antic anti-cancer drug
delegate and the k562 cells lower left
graph cookies in a pop that excels
becomes inactive and AFC production is
significantly slower producing
significantly lower look fluorescent
signal in actively cooled Kiku reader
reaction rate is slower and fluorescence
signal is slower in comparison to the
cinema obtained in under the nautical
reader in the biofluorescence reaction
signal continuously arises like as you
see here because more and more
fluorophore it's produced and it
accumulates in the reaction volume
contrary to bioluminescence reactions
where substrate is depleted by reactions
causing the luminescent signal to
decrease the slide this slide highlights
how sensitive ration signal is to even
small temperature variations you are
looking at luminescence kinase glow
signal overtime shown in red is the
curve produced by a not cooled reader
operating at 35 degrees Celsius internal
temperature temperature and vertical
spark was adjusted in small increments
and kinase glow as his signal measured
repeatedly with each temperature
increase of 1.5 degree Celsius signal
intensity increases the normalized graph
on variety shows how much faster the
reaction substrate consumption is on
verse subsequence and system
second signal decrease on the not called
reader red curve different Belarusian
sizes are affected to different degrees
by the temperature in some biome lessons
as is for example cell title glow as it
the signal increased cause with the
temperature is small only about five
percent the largest and civil increase
of about twenty percent was observed for
example UDP glow a sea and the largest
up to 40 percent signal increase effect
caused by wedge that temperature was
observed for succinate glow and ADP glow
edges this observed time effect on the
signal prompted acid developers to
introduce their pre read incubation
times of 10 to 15 minutes in way asses
this was presumably to allow Luminess
air signals stabilized before
measurements but as my work indicates
this incubation time it's not necessary
and may increase overall variability of
the IC signal
this slide shows believe essence signal
changes over time as blue curves and the
signal present severe or coefficient on
signal variation changes in time as
ground
- curves scale from those severe curves
are on the right-hand side of a grass on
the left slide side data are displayed
from a different asses obtained on the
not cooled reader and on the right slide
side data for the tip will spark in all
graphs luminescence data behave as we
discussed earlier for the not code
reader
we observed several increase associated
with reaction temperature increase
and luminescence increase as absent for
the data obtained on the red tegu reader
but present CV or signal of efficient
coefficient of signal variation ground -
croaks is decreasing is increase in
creative time in all the grass this
signal abbreviation increase combined
with the overall signal decrease can
significantly negatively affect a cz
prime values top four graphs in the top
row illustrates with misconception that
waiting 10 or 15 minutes will allow
luminescent signal to stabilize as you
see here is no difference if you
dispense and measure or dispense
incubate and minutes and a very measured
luminescent signal for the not cold
instrument - top left graphs luminescent
circular increases independently where
you wait 10 minutes or not and where for
the tip will spark luminescent if signal
continuously decreases independent of 10
minutes incubation so again I want to
underline here that as it can be and
should be read right after dispensing
and mixing colors this can also
significantly reduce the processing time
for multiple plates but there is an
exception then complicated multi-step by
luminescence reactions are taking place
then much longer incubation times of
half an hour one hour one and a half
hour are required for their asses and
those incubation times should be upheld
now coming back from where I started the
idea of an internally cooled leader and
this work was instigated by my small
compact compound library screening
results low pack it's a library
collection of 1,280 pharmaceutically
active compounds provided by
sigma-aldrich this library is supplied
in a sixteen Dirac's with 80 compounds
per rack so 16 racks x 18 compound see
sequel was 1280 compounds low par
compounds for screening were dispensed
to nano liters per well by lacked
website eco acoustic dispenser into a
384 well plates i screamed the 80
compounds of the supplier light supplied
interact rat in quadruplicate in low 384
well plates so 80 compounds x 4 or
quadruple cuts is equal 320 walls and
they had still 64 walls left our
controls to screen all 1280 compounds
envelope ACK library required 16 created
for wall plates plate numbers and in the
green incredible bottom of a graph after
screening quadruplicate
results for each compound are averaged
and each average value is represented by
a single data point on the graph above
and if you look at the results from the
screens you see jigsaw pattern or
periodicity for each plate or every 18
data points now let's look there at cmp
glow se versus low back screen data on
the Left graph data were collected
collected on the not code reader and on
the right graph results were obtained on
the T cool spark reader
Tikku results appear significantly
smoother barcode creating the prime
values for each plate you can save a
signal difference between not code and
actively cooled readers the lower bar
chart shows the prime values for each of
sixteen plates it is on a vertical
instrument are shown as blue bars and
reads on the not cooled reader are shown
as brown bars all blue bars are
significantly higher the average the
prime values for the 16 plates obtained
invade cuckoo equipped instrument blue
dash line is opened one unit higher
compared to the average the prime values
for an odd code reader light brown dash
line Z prime calculations for section 8
glow as in reveal even larger difference
between Z prime values obtained on cold
and not old instruments the Z prime
values averaged over 16 plates for a
typical reader I improved by 0.2 whole
units it's a big difference on both
table graphs varied red dash line
indicates free x standard deviation line
which marks limit below which compounds
can be selected as a heads for active
compounds as you see on well not code
reader on the Left graph we can count
just 5 compounds appearing below 3
standard deviations line as on vertical
instrument data we can identify by the
same as he 24 active compounds
when this slide I show relations graphs
of a data obtained on cold versus not
cold reader for two asses for both ices
green rectangles mark higher activity
points obtained on the not cold reader
caused by the temperature
equilibration effect the greater spread
of a data obtained on we're not good
reader significantly impacts the ability
to distinguish the real health now the
adverse effects of reaction volume
heating on signal variability can be
successfully mitigated by pre-warming
blades before taking the measurements
rewarming can be done inside the reader
especially if just a one or couple plays
are being measured
but rewarming also can be performed
inside the dedicated incubator set to
the temperatures matching the readers
internal operating temperature all data
on this slide represents measurements on
not cooled reader the same GPAs glow as
he top-left graph shows data obtained
from a place measured at ambient
temperature and and the top right graph
show data obtained their plates
pre-warming in dedicated incubator for
ten minutes each clearly top left graph
screen results devout pre-warming plates
are already very good the average of a
plates over 0.87 indicated very
successful screen and robust a see but
the warming of a plates even further
increases the z prime average up to 0.93
laura graph illustrates the benefits of
pre-warming plates as related by
the prime caleche calculations for all
place diff and without pre-warming place
pre-warming as he played raises the
prime average by open zero six units so
excessively pre-warning can successfully
mitigate the results scattering caused
by action temperature increase inside
the reader
unfortunately play pre-warming SI also
time and resources consuming step so in
this presentation i showed that
bioluminescence and biofluorescence
reaction rates are affected by the
readers internal temperature even small
temperature changes have significant
effect on the reaction rate different
biochemical reactions are affected by
the temperature by different different
degrees after reagent addition and
mixing incubation time of ten to fifteen
minutes usually for most reaction is not
necessary and might be detrimental
reading plays just after dispensing
without the pre incubation results in
significant time savings during played
as multi-plate processing pre-warming
plays solve problem caused by a plate
heating inside the reader but it also
consumes time and the resources thank
you for your attention thank you so much
doctor very gracious for that important
research I'd now like to turn our
presentation to the second part dr.
Catherine Fletcher welcome thank you
Susie and thank you getting enough for
this interesting summary of your
measurement on the next couple of slides
I would like to give you a brief
overview how active cooling inside a
multimode Raider can be accomplished
the reader that was used for the studies
described in the previous slides and in
fact the only multimode reader currently
on the market that possesses an
integrated cooling function is the spark
reader by Tekin
the spark is a multi modular reader
platform that combines a number of
different functions and readout modes
for all kinds of research objectives and
application requirements it is a
spectrometer
it is analyzer reader it is a dual
channel dispenser it can be used as a
luminometer as a cell counter and even
as a semi automated microscope all in
one box as you can see the SPARC unites
many different functions and modules it
offers all the most popular detection
modes like absorbance fluorescence
luminescence alpha screen fluorescence
polarization etc etc and it also comes
with many available accessories like
reagent injectors a tool to prevent
fluid evaporation and of course with a
very useful and easy to use software
that is called spark controlled in the
context of this webinar the functions
that we would like to focus on are the
integrated heating and cooling functions
of the instrument the cooling function
specifically is called the T cool module
so first of all the spark instrument is
able to heat up the measurement chamber
from 3 degrees Celsius over ambient up
to 42 degrees Celsius this is especially
useful for cell based applications
mostly with eukaryotic cells that
require a temperature that resembles
more or less the physiological body
temperature 37 degrees for optimal
growth and proliferation the software of
the reader enables simple and
straightforward definition of a target
temperature which will
reached within minutes and maintained
over days is needed with the uniformity
across the plate of 99.5 percent so a
results variation of less than 0.5
percent across an entire plate the
temperature function is indeed part of
the basic configuration of every spark
reader so every instrument will be
equipped with this heating function and
it can of course be combined with
various other functions designed for
cell based assays not only for cell
based assays but this is in my
experience the most popular application
field for these so-called environmental
control features so researchers
typically want to do long term cell
growth studies and in this context the
heating function and the ability of the
instrument to maintain a target
temperature of 37 degrees is most useful
but it's not only a heating function
that the spark possesses it's in fact
the first reader on the market that not
only has the ability to heat the
measurement chamber but also permits
lowering the operation temperature below
ambient the minimum temperature that can
be reached with this system at the
moment is 18 degrees so that's well
below the normal room temperature level
it may not actually be like refrigerator
conditions but it meets the requirements
of many temperature sensitive probes and
samples and in addition it helps to
maintain a constant temperature during
long term kinetic measurements by
actively preventing instrument heating
so how is this cooling function
accomplished the spark reader when
equipped with the so-called t cool
module is a two component system it uses
a special external and internal part the
external water cooling unit chills the
water outside of the instrument and this
is then used to cool
or as a cooling medium which is pumped
back into the readers internal cooling
module to cool the air inside the reader
and the air that has been warmed up
during operation is pumped back to the
cooling module to the external part
cooled again and then returned to the
reader and this cycle serves to maintain
a specified temperature if needed below
ampion ambient temperature even for
long-term measurement periods so even
for several days if needed so why is a
constant
sorry yeah here we go why is a constant
s a temperature so important well first
of all scientific studies done in
different labs in different parts of the
world should still have the same outcome
if they are performed in the same way a
scientist in Stockholm Sweden should be
able to reproduce the results of another
scientist in San Diego California
when using the same sample same s a
chemistry and the same experimental
setup the components of the experiment
should react and behave in the same way
no matter in which climate conditions
the SA is performed in reality this is
hardly ever the case reagents and other
si components particularly enzymes and
other temperature sensitive components
have temperature Optima so that means
best working conditions and they may
lose a significant portion of their
activity when used outside this optimal
operation temperature or the target
temperature range so for repre do Segel
and comparable results it is vital to
maintain a defined target temperature at
which the si is performed day by day in
addition the reaction kinetics shouldn't
be influenced by temperature increases
in the lab throughout the course of the
day so we all know in the mornings it
tends to be a little cooler than at
and in the afternoon especially during
these long summer days hot summer days
the temperature in the lab can really
rise significantly and all of this
shouldn't influence the dynamics of your
essays so using any type of temperature
stabilizing function like the T cool
module will make your results much more
reliable and reproducible one of the
first scientists to find out about the
susceptibility of chemical and
biological reactions to temperature was
Jacobus Henricus vant Hoff a Dutch
physical chemist and the winner of the
first Nobel Prize in Chemistry his
pioneering work helped found the modern
theory of chemical affinity equilibrium
chemical kinetics and chemical
thermodynamics he stipulated that
enzymatic activity is directly dependent
on temperature and the corresponding
equation that is still the basis for
these findings is named after him the so
called vant Hoff equation he found that
for example the speed of a chemical
reaction is increased by up to 12% if
the temperature is increased by only 1
degree Celsius which can lead to a
variation in the final measurement
results of even 10 to 20% so really a
significant change just based on
fluctuations in the temperature level
and his findings can be easily confirmed
in many modern day scientific
applications as we can see here on this
slide the signal uniformity of replicate
samples can drastically vary when an SI
is performed at different temperature
levels the green line is how it should
be you could say a constant temperature
throughout the entire measurement period
means lowest possible cv lowest possible
results variation so this is what every
researcher should aim for providing a
constant temperature
for the SA set up throughout the entire
measurement period in contrast if the
temperature increased by 4 or 8% as was
the case in this example experiment here
you can see a massive results change so
a massive increase in the signal itself
but also a massive increase in the CB
the coefficient of variation of the
replicate samples particularly the
reaction surface from the temperature
increase during the readout which as you
can see leads to an accelerating slope
of the signal curve that becomes more
profound the higher the temperature gets
so this is exactly what the T cool
function of the spark reader is intended
for maintaining a constant temperature
even if the ambient temperature in the
lab Rises throughout the analysis period
and in addition having the option to
control temperature inside your either
even below ambient opens up
possibilities for new applications for
example you can mimic the water
temperature conditions for marine
organisms which usually like a
surrounding temperature of 18 to 20
degrees so that makes it an ideal tool
to study the responses of marine species
to climate changes for example and in
addition many bacterial cell cultures
have a growth optimum around 20 degrees
or lower these applications can also
benefit from having a cooled reader
which for example can be used to
simulate simulate growth conditions in
the food industry or in agriculture
where researchers are interested in
finding out which temperature conditions
are critical for microbial growth so
just to name a few examples where cool
detection instrument can be beneficial
for best possible results at the moment
we as t can have some ongoing
corporations about these topics and
about new application fields we're
actively cooled microplate
can can be helpful so I expect I will be
able to tell you more about these
applications in one of our next webinars
hopefully so to summarize these findings
or enter information on the last couple
of slides and to give you an overview of
the most important and useful advantages
of active cooling in the reader with an
active cooling system like the T cool
module for the spark reader you can
always measure on the defined
temperature conditions no matter what
time of day or year independently of the
location of your lab you can perform
essays below room temperature without
having to work in a cold laboratory you
can decrease the results variation of
the coefficient of variation of your
measurements by avoiding the instrument
from heating up during the measurement
you can study new species with special
growth or metabolic requirements for
example bacterial insect cells or marine
organisms and lastly you can speed up
the cooldown times after experiments at
elevated temperature which is especially
useful if many research groups have to
share one and the same instruments so
all of these benefits make the t cool
function of the SPARC reader very much
suited for modern-day research so with
this I would like to conclude thank you
for listening I hope you found the
content of this webinar interesting and
relevant for your scientific work and I
would like to thank you for your
attendance
thank you to both of you for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of your presentation window type
your questions into the box that appear
on the screen and click that send button
we'll answer as many as we can during
the presentation so let's look at our
first questions from our audience
members we have quite a wonderful
audience today our first question comes
in from Rick does the temperature inside
a multi-functional plate reader depend
on well I think I'm going to answer this
well primarily it depends on the reader
design the main heat sources are all
types of electronic components the power
supply inside the reader the light
sources so for example the flash lamp or
the laser whatever light source is used
in a particular reader and the longer
these components are switched on and
running the more heat will build up
inside the reader so that is sort of the
main contributor to instrument warming
it also somewhat depends on how old the
instrument is because over time dust can
accumulate inside the instrument and
prevent efficient ventilation so very
old instrument will probably show higher
temperature related results variations
than a brand new and modern reader in
addition modern readers such as spark
will have encapsulated measurements
cameras that are better protected from
ambient factors like light temperature
and of course contamination so they will
be better suited for a temperature
sensitive essay wonderful thank you
ah sure our next question is you
mentioned pre-warming as a surrogate for
cooling the reading chamber but doesn't
pre-warming increase the reaction rate
of the enzyme by prolonging incubation
now this is Gary Badou Gary's I believe
this question to me more regulated
you're right
plate pre warming will increase reaction
rate and will not reflect the reaction
behavior expected at room temperature
but real purpose of a play pre warming
is to achieve more even less dispersed
data and statistically better better
result it is more important during this
cleaning campaigns it allows smaller
signal variability and it allows
identification of more heat compounds
wonderful thank you and I want to thank
our audience members today we have some
wonderful questions coming in and we
appreciate your participation this next
question is for dr. Fletcher what which
assays are most susceptible in
temperature changes it's probably more
related to me again question I would say
that all chemical directions are equally
susceptible to the temperature change
but what we observe is that larger
effect we see in multi-step
bioluminescent sizes were probably
accumulation of an active reaction
intermediate takes place and this is
caused the larger signal increase during
12 Glade warming thank you so much we
have time for one more question from our
audience
this one is directed actually to dr.
Fletcher I already have a spark in my
lab but without T cool can I upgrade yes
you can
however it's a secre based upgrade so
the instrument has to be sent back to be
upgraded with the cooling module so with
the T cool module
I would recommend you contact your local
sales rep for more information on how to
do the upgrade and I'm sure they will be
glad to help you out on this wonderful
dr. vigorous and dr. Fletcher
we appreciate your presentation today do
you have any closing remarks you'd like
to share with the audience before we
close today I would like to take the
opportunity to thank everybody for
listening in it was so exciting for us
to share the results of our cooperation
and I'm really grateful for everybody
who listened in today thank you
from komagawa were happy to use the cool
module spark reader to work with our
asses which helped you know to achieve a
better result thank you thank you thank
you both and thank our audience members
I'd also like to thank lab roots and T
can our sponsor today for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through April 2018
you'll receive an email from laborat
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thanks so much
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon bye bye